is there somebody that you have in mind
let's assume that you beat Dylan and
let's assume you have
three four five more big fights yeah is
there is there like an end goal
I would or is there a dream fight nah no
I I would like to fight Connor I think
it'd be really cool I think it'd be real
do you think you're too big for him
I could I could cut to 185 and he's he's
like 180 170. what are you now you
probably are two 200 what okay so you
could cut just if you're cutting water
and everything I could get there no yeah
but size wise Connor was most effective
at
145. yeah but we'll always come back to
like he's a professional fighter I'm a
YouTuber you know and so that's supposed
to be the give and take of it like he
like why why would I a YouTuber who's
owned one have any business beating the
great Conor McGregor like on paper
[Applause]
[Laughter]
some of those dialects are hard